from superhero action thrillers to
down-to-earth dramas and everything in
between here are all the returning TV
shows that will blow you away in 2019
it looks like HBO's True detective is
determined to redeem itself after it's
unfortunate sophomore slump featuring an
all-new all-star cast the show's third
season has a solid foundation from which
it can spin out into the mind-bending
antics we've all come to love and expect
the new episodes will follow state
detective Wayne Hays his partner Roland
and schoolteacher
Amelia Reardon as they investigate the
mysterious disappearance of children in
southern Missouri during the 1980s much
like the show's groundbreaking first
season the third installment will take
place across separate time periods
telling its story through flashback and
flash-forward sequences judging by the
teaser trailer HBO unveiled for the new
season
it seems that fans should prepare
themselves for a wild and emotional ride
when true detective airs On January 3rd
2019 just who will win the Iron Throne
that question has perplexed fantasy fans
for over 20 years and should finally be
answered in 2019 when HBO airs the final
season of their wildly popular fantasy
drama Game of Thrones these episodes
which may run up to two hours long based
on reports are also said to be the
show's costliest yet with one of their
huge battle set pieces allegedly taking
a whopping 55 days to film rest assured
your grace you can count on the iron
bank support as soon as the gold arrives
considering the show already has a huge
body count it seems fairly safe to
expect that quite a few fan favorite
characters could end up biting the dust
in the show's final season to set your
DVRs now this isn't going to be a season
you want to miss 2019 is going to be a
strange year not least because the third
season of Netflix is sci-fi hits
stranger things is set to hit the
streaming platform this time around the
story will span eight episodes down from
the usual ten and will feature the
Hawkins gang dealing with all new forces
of evil the series is also set to
feature another time jump and will be
set in the summer a notable departure
from the last two seasons although
details are few and far between on just
where the show will go next plot wise we
do know a few details including the fact
that it'll feature more of season 2 fan
favorite Erica as
another likely appearance from Kali you
should help to open up more of the
mystery surrounding Elevens past sister
sister Claire Foy may be leaving her
post as Queen Elizabeth for season 3 of
Netflix's the crown but someone equally
decorated will assume the throne golden
globe-winning star Olivia Colman will
portray her Royal Highness in her later
years season 3 will also see a slew of
new cast members take over other roles
these include Helena Bonham Carter will
play an older version of Princess
Margaret tobias menzies taking on Matt
Smith's role as Prince Philip and Ben
Daniels becoming the new Lord Snowdon
and that's just a hint of what's to come
in the third season of the crown which
will chronicle events such as the a burr
fan disaster Princess Margaret's
five-year affair with rowdy Llewellyn
and Harold Wilson's tenure as Prime
Minister fans will also become
acquainted with Camilla parker-bowles
the second wife of Prince Charles as
well as the late Princess Diana big
little lies was a massive hit for HBO on
its release last year earning award
season love across the board for its
stars Reese Witherspoon Nicole Kidman
shailene woodley and Laura Dern although
the show was initially billed as a
limited series it wasn't all that
surprising when HBO ordered a second
season to be written by season 1 veteran
David E Kelly season 2 will also be
drawn from a story by Leon Moriarty the
author of the book on which the series
is based the main cast is all set to
return with transparent and American
honey director Andrea Arnold taking the
director's chair if that's not enough
big little eyes has also added another
huge name to its cast Meryl Streep set
to play the mother of Alexander
Skarsgard character Perry Joe Penhall
and David Fincher's gripping gory and
groovy 70s crime drama is coming back
for more later next year mind Hunter was
renewed by Netflix for a second season
right after the release of the first
which chronicled the efforts of FBI
agents Holden Ford billed tench and
psychologist Wendy Carr to establish the
behavioral science unit at the FBI
Academy interviewing serial killers in
the hopes of understanding the
motivations behind their grisly crimes
was just part of the job you want
truffles you got to get in the dirt with
the pigs Fincher has previously told
Billboard that mine hunters third season
will center around the notorious Atlanta
child murders which took place between
1979 and 1981 real-life FBI agent John E
Douglas on who
the show's Holden character is based
profiled a man named Wayne Williams
believing him to be one of the
perpetrators Williams eventually went to
jail but Douglass's actions and getting
him there resulted in him being censured
by the FBI given Holden's breakdown at
the end of the first season it wouldn't
be surprising if he becomes a little
more radical in his methods as the
second progresses